تداعى الناس هنا في مدينه مروي وادو صلاه
العيد صباح اليوم ونحن الان داخل المقر
الفرقه التاسعه عشره مشاهده الجيش
السوداني حيث اقيمت صلاه العيد هنا في هذه
في هذه الساحه
نشاهد هذه الصور
يهنئ
الضباط والضباط الصف والجنود بعضهم صلاه
العيد داخل المقر القياده
بمدينه مروي كانت بحضور والي الولايه
الشماليه وكذلك قائد الفرقه التاسعه عشر
مشاه بمدينه مروي وتحدث والي الولايه
الشماليه هنا للمصلين من الجنود والضباط
في الجيش السوداني وذكرهم بضروره يعني
تجاوز هذه المرحله وكذلك ضروره حسم ما
سماه التمرد اذا المظاهر مظاهر موجوده هنا
في مدينه مروي وكذلك في موازاه ذلك هذه
هناك مظاهر ايضا للانتشار الامني
والعسكريه في عدد من الشوارع في مدينه
مروي لاحظنا انتشار واسع للاليات العسكريه
التابعه للجيش السوداني في الشوارع وتجوب
عددا من الشوارع وترتكز بعضها امام بعض
المنشات
ومؤسسات المهمه وتقوم بعمليات تامين
المدينه امتداد طبعا
للتامين العسكري الذي تقوم به القوات
المسلحه السودانيه في اعقاب العمليات
العسكريه
المكثفه في مواجهه
القوات الدعم السريع